Hello Charles.
>> Hi Michael.
>> How are you today?
>> I'm doing just fine. How are you doing?
>> Alright. I'm a little out of practice with
this lecturing thing. So, I hope this goes well.
>> I'm absolutely sure it will.
>> So, today's lesson is continuing what you were talking about in
terms of Game Theory. But, I'm going to be focusing in on what happens
when you are worried about making decisions. With more than one player in
a sequence. Which we started to get into at the end of your
discussion but I'm going to go, more into it.
>> Okay. I really like the logo by the way.
>> Thanks very much. Yeah, it's a, it's a specially game theory logo.
>> I like it very much, I like it very much. I
will point out, however, that all sequels should be called the quickening.
>> Yeah, I was going to go with the quickening. Or
judgement day, but I didn't, didn't think that made any sense.
>> Hm, that's a fair point.